Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
I have a question. Let's start off
tonight with a very brief and quick
question.
What is it that saved
Yunuson?
What is it that saved him after being
swallowed by the whale?
That's what saved him. What do you say
before being swallowed by the whale?
Anyone else?
Let me ask you a question. So,
he's swallowed by a whale, right? This
is horrifying beyond
belief. Okay. And he was in a
Sovat here is plural
and in Arabic the least of plural is
three not two is three.
So he was in
And Allah tells us that he was in the
darkness of the belly, the darkness of
the water, the darkness of the night.
What's interesting is that before that
he was he did what is called
What does all this mean? So, Yunam
called his people.
His people were a big city, not a small
one. more than 100,000 residents.
More than 100,000. This is a huge city.
He called them to Islam. They refused
his message. They refused his message.
They refused his message.
And so, Yunus decided to what? to go
deliver this message elsewhere to a
different people, a people that would be
more thankful for this message. However,
Yunas did not have permission from Allah
to do that. He was sent to these people,
not those people over there.
And so,
as Ununas left, he got on a boat to
cross the water.
And while they were on this boat, the
boat was to capacity and actually he was
taken on the boat without any without
any payment because they knew him. They
knew he was a righteous man. He was a
good man. And so they took him on for
free. But then the water got very
chaotic.
And as they were in the water, they
realized that we have too much weight on
the boat. Some people are going to have
to go and someone is going to have to
take one for the team.
So how do they make such a decision? Who
is going to die so that the rest can
live?
So they decided to draw straws. What we
call draw drawing straws. in older
English it would be referred to as
drawing lots. In the Quran it is
referred to as mahana.
And what that means is that they will do
something that will randomize the
option. We say in English drawing straws
which means that for instance you have a
number of straws they all appear to be
the same length. Whoever draws the straw
that is shortest that's the one that
gets caught with it. It wasn't in this
exact way but it was the same concept.
And so the first time it comes out as
Ununus, they say, "No way are we going
to throw Eunos of all people overboard
this ship. Let's do it again." They drew
again and it was Ununas.
They said, "No way. We can't we can't we
can't live with ourselves to throw this
man. This is the best of us." So they
did it again and it was Ununas.
And so they continued doing this,
refusing to throw Eunas overboard. But
Yunas,
he understood something. He understood
that this is about him. And that if they
were to draw those straws for a million
years, it would always be him. And so
Eunas jumped overboard.
And when he did, a whale
came and gobbled him up.
I I can think of few things on this
earth more horrifying than that. I mean,
in you know, in in in cartoons like
Pinocchio, right? It's a cute kind
of thing. the whale swallows him
and he's sitting in there and he's got a
lamp and a desk and he's sitting there
writing stuff, right? It's so cute. This
is not cute at all. This is absolutely
horrifying.
Can you imagine the claustrophobia?
Could you imagine the crush? Could you
imagine the pain and the fear?
And not only that, but the acids of this
giant monster start to eat the skin
right off of his body.
And so in this situation, he says,
"Is that a dua?"
Did he say, "Oh Allah, allow me to live.
Take me back to the shore. Save me." Did
he say that? And maybe had something of
that in his heart. But the prophets and
messengers, they do not ask for things
that they are unsure whether they will
be good or bad for them. They leave it
to Allah's discretion. You'll see this
all through the Quran when it comes to
things that they are sure are good such
as Allah's forgiveness such as paradise
such as they ask for it by name they
specify oh Allah give me paradise oh
Allah
oh Allah you know
oh Allah
right these are things that they are
sure are good for them But then other
things being healed from an
illness, being delivered from the belly
of a whale, given something of the
dunya, what is their dua? It is actually
an expression of oh Allah give me what
is best for me.
So says
I'm in pain.
but unto your discretion
said
whatever you got for me I need it
desperately
said
he didn't say spare me from this because
maybe it is better for him to stay in
there. Maybe it is better to be digested
by a whale.
You don't know. You don't know. Maybe
this illness will go away and that will
seal your fate because health is what
will swindle you off of the path of
Allah.
And maybe that as long as you are ill,
you will be grateful. You will be
conscious. You will be aware. You will
be connected.
And what is what good is health if it
leads you to disbelief?
What good is strength if it is the cause
for your transgression? This is what the
prophets understand about this and that
is why Allah teaches us something about
ourselves.
The human being makes dua for that which
is bad for him with the same fervor that
he does for that which is good. Why does
he do that? Because he doesn't know
what's good for him and he is impatient.
And a lot of what he says and does comes
from a place of impatience.
And so
makes this statement
and Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us
that had it not been for the fact that
he was of those who glorified Allah,
then he would have remained
in that
whale's belly until the day of
resurrection. Now, a lot of people
misunderstand this to mean that had it
not been for him making dua that moment.
But let me ask you a question. Is there
any human being on this earth? Imagine
the most arrogant,
the most atheist, the most disbelieving
scum of humanity. Imagine this person
get swallowed by a whale.
Would they make dua to Allah at that
point or not?
Huh?
Everyone makes dua at that point. At the
moment of death, is there anyone that
fails to become Muslim?
When the soul is being extracted from
the body, everyone at that moment says
what? says what said.
That's why a person's repentance is not
accepted when their soul is being
extracted from their body because that's
not particularly special. Everybody
makes dua and repents at that moment.
Everyone says
when they get swallowed by a whale,
everyone.
Pharaoh Elim himself will make the
purest of dua in that situation.
That's not what saves you here. What
saves you is his relationship
and the buildup of his relationship with
Allah before he got swallowed by the
whale.
That's what really makes the difference
that before he reached that moment of
dire need of Allah,
he had a history with Allah. Do we know
the story the narration of Abdullahb
Omar and Bkari Muslim the story of the
the three men who went into a cave for
the night and a boulder closed the cave
on him.
And so each of them made dua for what?
They made dua and they made
with their good deeds.
And what saved them from that was what?
Their dua at that moment. Everyone is
going to become a Muslim if they get
trapped in a cave.
But what saved them was? their good
deeds, their account with Allah, their
history with Allah that they could draw
from
to use at that most dire instance.
And this is the meaning or one of the
meanings of the statement of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala when he says
[Silence]
The statement of Allah remember me, make
mention of me and I shall make mention
of you or remember me and I will
remember you. It has two meanings.
Meaning that every time you say Allah's
name, every time you remember Allah,
Allah makes mention of your name in the
heavens. And it also means that
what our prophet told Ib Abbas when he
was riding with him in that very famous
narration he said
worship Allah get to know Allah acquaint
yourself with Allah acquaint yourself to
Allah in your times of ease and he will
remember you in your time of difficulty.
This is what saved Yunas.
What saved Yunas was his history with
Allah. And so when we stand and this is
also mentioned as what saved S
from Nam
when Sarah Ibraim's wife was taken by a
tyrannical king a tyrannical king that
perhaps puts Found to shame
this tyrannical king took him and SIM
she drew from her previous relationship
with Allah. Oh Allah, if you know me to
be a believer in you, then protect me
from this from this man.
And so on it goes. This is what
separates the believer from the
disbeliever. It's not what you do in
your times of difficulty. It's what we
do in our times of ease.
And so every time you make salah, every
time you stand for prayer, you must
understand that you will have hard days
ahead of you. Every one of us. There's
not one of us here that's not going to
die. There's not one of us here that's
not going to be faced with calamities.
There's not one of us here that will
shed
a bucket of tears before departing from
this earth. Every one of us. However,
every time you go to pray, every time
you fast, every time you remember Allah,
in those times of ease, comfort, safety,
health, remember Allah. And know that
the only most loyal is Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala. That is true loyalty. and
true loyalty that he not only is a
shakur means that he thanks those who
thank him but he subhanahu wa ta'ala
will not just be at your beckoned call
he subhanahu wa ta'ala will give you
what you need at your most confused and
weak of states
Subhanahu wa tala.
[Silence]
Subhan Allah.
Is it just me or is it hot in here?
[Arabic recitation]